hey 42 here it's no secret that
Hollywood has a habit of playing fast
and loose with the truth in the name of
entertainment and we all know that the
words based on real events are actually
code for we made 90 of the plot up to
make it more interesting there's a long
list of movies based on so-called true
stories that have been significantly
spiced up for the Silver Screen from
Catch Me If You Can to the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre
the Revenant starring Leonardo DiCaprio
is another good example released in 2015
to critical Acclaim the film tells a
story of American Frontiersman Hugh
glass who gets horrifically mauled by a
grizzly bear before going on an epic
journey to wreak his revenge on The Men
Who abandoned him in the aftermath it
sounds like textbook Hollywood Hyperbole
and the Revenant certainly took some
serious liberties with the truth in fact
outside of the bear mauling itself
almost every major plot point in the
entire film is utter nonsense
but here's the funny thing whilst is
absolutely true that Hollywood had its
Wicked way with Hugh glass's story if
anything the fictional retelling was
actually significantly less epic than
the real events of his life I mean they
didn't even mention the part where he
was forced to become a pirate or the bit
where he watched his friend burns alive
with slivers of superheated pine
no I'm not making that up this is the
true story of Hugh glass a tale so
incredible Hollywood toned it down to
make it more believable
now I have to admit I get frustrated
when companies treat my personal data
like a commodity that can be bought sold
and auctioned to the highest bidder and
recently it's been an issue that's been
concerning me even more since the number
of data breaches worldwide is on the
rise in 2021 there were 68 more breaches
than the year before there are hundreds
of data Brokers out there but did you
know there are many different types too
such as marketing data Brokers that
collate your online browsing habits and
sell it on for marketing purposes
there's also financial information
Brokers that collect your financial and
background information and sell it to
credit companies and Banks it's all
incredibly concerning if you ask me so
that's why I'm using incognee incognee
reaches out to data Brokers on your
behalf requests your personal data
removal and deals with objections from
their side I remember I once looked at a
sofa online just once and ever since
I've been seeing advertisements for that
same sofa and others all around the web
I don't know about you but I don't take
too kindly to being stalked by furniture
and that's why I love incognate because
it can help put an end to such absurdity
in Cockney is available risk-free for 30
days meaning anyone can try it out for
themselves and get a full refund if they
aren't happy with the service so click
the link below in the description and
the first 100 people to use the code 42
will get 20 off in cognate thanks to
incogni for sponsoring this video
we don't know a whole heap about Hughes
early life but he was probably born
sometime around 1783 near Philadelphia
these days we know him as a famous
Frontiers man and bear-knuckled boxer of
bears but when he first pinged into
existence on history's radar he was
actually a sailor his ship was attacked
by Pirates somewhere off the coast of
what is now Texas in 1819. most of the
crew were killed but after acquitting
himself particularly well in the fight
glass was given a choice Ally with the
Pirates or join the rest of his crew
leaking blood and guts on the deck after
deliberating for several microseconds
glass chose the former
as is the case with most bold career
changes becoming a pirate wasn't easy
for one thing there was a lot more
raping and pillaging than glass was used
to and despite having a solid work ethic
he never really took to it
at what I like to think of as his first
pirate annual appraisal glass's new boss
the notorious pirate Jean Lafitte was
not pleased as punishment for his
perceived crimes glass was set to stand
Trail before Lafitte besides another
condemned crew member both men knew
their fate would be a long walk from a
short plank
so they made a run for it which quickly
became a swim for it
they were two miles out to sea at the
time but somehow both of them made it to
shore alive where they set about living
off the land avoiding search parties and
trying not to get eaten by cannibals
[Music]
they were in carencara territory a
Native American tribe well known for
their predilection for human flesh
I should point out that there's no
evidence to Karen Caro were actually
cannibals the rumor seems to have been
started by Spanish colonists and it
stuck
still glass and his body didn't know
that and quite understandably they had
no intention of putting it to the test
keeping a low profile the two men headed
north in search of friendly settlements
700 miles later in what is now Kansas
they were captured by members of the
Pony Tribe
now on the bright side the pony weren't
cannibals
on the [ __ ] side they did practice
ritual Human Sacrifice yay soon after
they were caught glass's traveling
companion was stripped naked and burnt
at the stake as he died his riving body
was stabbed repeatedly with burning
splinters of pine wood glass would have
been next but as the tribesmen began to
prepare him for the ceremony he reached
into his pocket and produced a vial of a
red ore called Cinnabar which he
presented to the tribe's Chief with a
deep bow and awaited his fate with
dignity
Cinnabar was highly prized by the pony
and the chief was so impressed with the
gift as well as the gravity and respect
with which it had been given that not
only did he spare glass's life he
accepted him into the tribe it's thought
that glass went on to live with the pony
for several years and there's a pretty
good chance his later Feats of survival
were made possible at least in part by
the things he learned from them so there
you have it Boba Fett was actually a
prequel to the Revenant anyway he left
the tribe sometime in the early 1820s
making his way to Saint Louis where he
responded to an advert to join the
recently formed and soon to be world
famous Rocky Mountain Fur Company the
company founded by William Ashley and
Andrew Henry were seeking tough men to
join a 2 000 mile Expedition up the
Missouri River to the recently
established Fort Henry which was to
serve as a base for fur trapping both on
the river itself and in the Rocky
Mountains to the West the men who joined
that now legendary Expedition will come
to be known as Ashley's 100 and they
were some of the toughest men ever to
have lived including some now household
names like Jedediah Smith and Jim
Bridger
progress of the river in two large boats
was slow but steady until an attack by
members of the arakara tribe left 14 of
glass's new colleagues dead and many
more injured
glass himself was shot in the leg during
the Skirmish and the men were forced
back down river
Founders William Ashley and Andrew Henry
had sunk a huge amount of capital into
the Expedition and returning home
empty-handed simply wasn't an option if
the fledgling company was to survive
with the Missouri deemed too dangerous
the group split into two one led by
Ashley went West in search of beaver and
immediate profits whilst the other led
by Henry and including glass went North
to Fort Henry on foot in the hope of
bypassing the arakara
the plan was only partially successful
and the group ended up in several more
minor skirmishes with the locals but for
glass the biggest danger wouldn't come
from muskets and tomahawks but teeth and
claws
he was out hunting wonder when he heard
a sudden commotion in the undergrowth
he turned to see a massive shape
hurtling towards him at full speed and
he had just enough time to raise his
rifle on fire before the creature was on
him
if you've seen the Revenant you'll know
exactly what happens next glass had
inadvertently Disturbed a mother grizzly
bear and her Cubs Grizzlies aren't
exactly friendly at the best of times
but her mother with her young is the
dictionary definition of overprotective
glass was mauled to an inch of his life
now the way the story is usually told he
managed to stab the bear to death during
the struggle but the truth is an adult
Grizzly and full-on attack mode is
practically Invincible once it gets up
close and chances are it was glass's
companions alerted by his screams who
brought the bear down for sustained
muscle fire
to begin with they thought glass was
dead too until someone noticed his chest
was still rising and falling amazingly
death was not yet calling but one of his
legs was broken and his back was so
badly lacerated that his ribs were
visible beneath his bloodied skin
it was obvious to everyone that glass
wouldn't last so they made him as
comfortable as they could strapped him
to a makeshift stretcher and continued
on their way
they didn't get far glass was a dead
weight severely hampering their Pace in
this treacherous place they were still
in arakara territory after all
with little of a choice Henry offered a
reward of 80 the equivalent of a couple
of Grand in today's money to any men who
would stay behind with glass in his
final hours to give him a proper
Christian burial two men stepped forward
the first was a veteran Trapper named
John Fitzgerald and the second was a 17
year old Rocky identified only as
Bridger some historians believed it was
probably Jim Bridger who would go on to
become one of the world's most famous
Frontiers men of the old American West
[Music]
Fitzgerald and Bridger no doubt assumed
they were going to make some easy cash
glass was a death's door with the only
sign he hadn't already been invited
inside for tea and hobnobs with the Grim
Reaper being the occasional flicker of
the eyes but day after day went by and
whilst glass certainly wasn't getting
any better
he wasn't dead either
Fitzgerald and Bridger were getting
Twitchy nobody had expected glass to
live this long and eighty dollars was
beginning to look like inadequate
compensation for this dangerous task
after five days went by with no sign of
glass expiring they decided to act they
took his rifle knife and Flint and left
him for dead the two men reached Fort
Henry just a couple of days after the
rest of the group and Julie confirmed
that glass was dead and buried safe in
the knowledge that there was no way he
could possibly come back and prove them
wrong
I'm guessing they'd never seen The Lion
King
glass meanwhile had broken from his
stupor still alive but in Dire Straits
he managed to splint his broken leg but
the rest of his injuries were beginning
to fester and he had no supplies or
survival gear pretty much the only thing
he did have was a burning desire to get
his revenge on the men who'd robbed him
and left him to die alone in the
wilderness hundreds of miles from home
they say the Journey of a Thousand Miles
starts with a single step but that
assumes one can actually walk Hugh
Glasses Long rode back to civilization
most likely started with a three-inch
Scrabble and a very live scream
most people would have given up there
and then he was 300 miles from the
nearest settlement a small Trading Post
called Fort Kiowa
and the journey there presented a whole
host of Hazards but Hugh glass was not
most people he was an ex-pirate who
survived being shot in the leg and
mauled by a bear and who learned to
survive in the Wilds of North America
from the very people who'd lived there
for millennia
day by day he dragged himself onwards
drinking water from streams and mashing
passing insects into his mouth for
nourishment
after about a week of this pitiful
existence he stumbled across a pack of
walls feasting on a Buffalo Calf he
waited patiently for the Predators to
eat their fill then dragged himself over
to the carcass
it was a find that very probably saved
his life
he set up a makeshift camp nearby and
gorged on buffalo meat until his
strength returned
as he slowly recuperated he allowed
maggots to proliferate in the worst of
his wounds now that might sound like a
truly terrible idea but maggot therapy
is actually an FDA approved biotreatment
for various ailments even today
in glass's case deriving yellow larvae
ate away his Rotting Flesh preventing
gangrene he was still badly wounded but
when he set out again for Fort Kiowa he
was able to move far more freely
when he hit the Missouri River soon
afterwards he either borrowed a skin
boat from a friendly tribe of Lakota or
possibly fashioned his own depending on
which source you read either way the
next leg of his journey was
significantly smoother than the first he
simply floated down with her all the way
to Fort Kiowa arriving approximately six
weeks after his date with Destiny at the
pores of the grizzly
after this Epic Journey back to
civilization and safety you might think
Hugh glass would have put his feet up
for a bit but whilst most of his
physical injuries had healed the mental
ones had not the men who'd abandoned him
to die were still out there somewhere
living their lives as if nothing had
happened
glass was determined to put that right
after just a couple of days at the fort
he heard about a new Expedition heading
back up the Missouri in the direction of
Fort Henry where he assumed Fitzgerald
and Bridger would be waiting glass
signed up immediately it turned out to
be an eventful trip the expedition was
only due to go as far as a group of
villagers about halfway between Fort
Kiowa and Fort Henry and so glass
planned to hike the rest of the way on
his own
the day after he split with the other
members of the group they were ambushed
by the arakara and every single one of
them was slaughtered
glass did have a run-in with the arakara
himself he only narrowly escaped with
his life after Warriors from a rival
tribe came to his Aid when he finally
arrived at Fort Henry after six weeks on
the river and a month of solo hiking
instead of an epic showdown of the man
who'd runged him he found absolutely
nothing Fort Henry had been abandoned
and according to a note he found pasted
to the door relocated nearby
in the end he strode into Fort Henry 2.0
more than four months after he'd been
mauled by the grizzly the men stationed
at the Fort must have thought they were
seeing a ghost after all they had it on
good authority that glass was dead and
buried
not our friend Bridger though he knew
exactly what he was seeing a big [ __ ]
problem
I think everyone can relate to that
horrible sinking feeling you get when
someone catches you in a lie I'm
guessing Bridger felt it too only worse
because his lie was also pointing a gun
in his face in the end he needn't have
worried glass was out for Revenge but he
was also a reasonable man Bridger seemed
to be genuinely remorseful for his crime
and after pleading his case to Glass the
grizzled Frontiers man ultimately
decided that as the older man the real
blame lay with Fitzgerald
unfortunately Fitzgerald had left the
camp more than a month earlier to join
up with the Army at Fort Atkinson in
what is now Nebraska
but by this point winter had set in and
it was a full two months before glass
cut set off in not so hot pursuit
after another long hike and yet another
deadly run-in with the arakara glass
finally made it to Fort Atkinson where
he found himself face to face with John
Fitzgerald
glass was a simple man he didn't embark
on some long speech or ask Fitzgerald to
explain his actions he simply pulled out
his gun leveled it at Fitzgerald's head
and did absolutely nothing just at the
moment he'd been about to pull a trigger
a nearby army officer pointed out that
murdering a member of the American
Military In Cold Blood was a capital
offense in other words if glass shot
Fitzgerald he'd be hanged immediately
it must have taken a huge amount of
willpower to lower his weapon remember
what he'd come through to get to this
point but lower it he did however he
left Fitzgerald with a passing promise
if he ever left the protection of the
army glass would find him and he would
kill him
because he had a very particular set of
skills skills he'd acquired over a very
long career
glass would live on the American
frontier for the rest of his life
trapping trading hunting and exploring
he was a veteran of many battles of the
various tribes whose lands the United
States of America was slowly claiming
for its own
but it was in 1833 at the approximate
age of 50 that his luck finally ran out
he and two fellow Trappers were ambushed
by a large party of arakara Braves
whilst crossing a frozen River they were
all shot robbed and finally sculpt
in the years since Hugh glass's
remarkable story has quite rightly
achieved legendary status
but as with many legendary Tales there's
a fairly good chance that some of it
isn't true much of what we know about
glass's life comes from sources that are
hard to trust entirely and Rumor Has It
Glass himself was fond of telling Tall
Tales particularly when they concerned
himself
exactly where we should draw that line
between fact and Fable is Up For Debate
but one thing's for certain even if on
the attempt of the story is told about
Hugh glass are true he was undeniably
one of the most remarkable men and
greatest survivors ever to have lived
foreign